hey guys what's up so I'm hanging out
with imagine dragons and we're in Las
Vegas right now
and you guys are gonna be performing
pretty much like in the middle the
street yeah exactly like in the middle
of the street in an intersection yeah
it's gonna where we're just blocking up
everything almost funny sis are you guys
tweet something about trying to keep it
a secret and it was impossible it's hard
to keep something a secret while
shutting down like three major roads in
downtown Las Vegas but you know we tried
you might need like crazy Twitter
experiences been that I mean daniel has
his own beard account that's kind of
cool I do there yeah dan had a rat tail
account but I guess when the rat tail
left the so does the account I don't
know we should obably check that I
shaved my mustache the day it got its
own Twitter account or somebody else no
I did presumably the mustache I've
started the mustache account so I saw
you guys perform at Video Game Awards
which you guys play video games or oh
yes do you've a favorite game a couple I
love like all the Final Fantasy stuff I
like League of Legends I like I mean I'm
a very like giving person so that lends
me to be a support role I support other
players as they win the game
I think Call of Duty Vidya you're
playing destiny yesterday what's what
you blanked I think I was the hunter I
was I could stab people in the face sons
later it's pretty crazy yeah Ben is the
best at original Donkey Kong of all of
us though he can like do it so you beat
it and you've backed a level one but
it's harder I've never made it that far
yes I am sort of like as Tommy is too
pinball bending about you guys have a
new album coming out just really really
soon what's that like kind of building
up to the big release of it difficult
yes it's exciting and exhilarating and
exhausting all at the same time yeah
we're in a place where we like we worked
on the music for so long and we just
can't wait to share it with everyone so
it's like a little nerve-wracking yeah
we created all this stuff that we are so
proud of when we've been wanting to
share with everybody but we've been
having to kind of keep it under wraps
and now that of the day that we can sort
of make it all public is approaching you
know it's
it's very exciting favorite place to
play this is a heart really difficult we
played fortunate enough to get to play
like some really amazing show South
Paulo Brazil last time we played there
for a lovable loser was one of the most
incredible shows Red Rocks in Colorado
is another one of those magical places
so tonight what are you guys performing
it's gonna be aired on the Grammys it's
just kind of crazies anything like it's
been done before I mean it's kind of
impressive you're right nothing
groundbreaking yeah
we're pretty excited we're gonna be
playing shots which is the first song on
the record so we thought it was a pretty
good way to kind of launch the record
which comes out on the 17th
so that's unless that's in a week less
than a week it's really something like
that yeah and yeah so we're sad to play
that tonight and kind of get our hands
dirty with the new record this would be
our first real experience with that so
really exciting and you guys seem like
fan covers that you've been like wow
this is amazing
yeah when we released warriors actually
there was a cover of metal group
European metal group did a cover of it
like with all this crazy shred guitar
and like screaming vocals and it was
really cool I think they retweeted it
you know there's a really cool like
bluegrass cover like old timey Americana
bluegrass cover of radioactive that was
really totally bizarre and pretty
wonderful I would say hi and yeah we're
excited for smoke commuters to come out
we're going on tour tickets are
available in the US 97 317th they're
already available worldwide for like
South America and Europe and yeah we
really put a lot into this record and
and we're really proud of it and we hope
that you like it as well and if you hate
it that's okay too
but just don't tell us about it right
okay yeah we love you we only want our
giving that's our only positive I did
listen to the previous transpose today
though which is very good okay you will
be training out maybe I'll see you guys
for destiny yeah sure I guess my
excellent sir PlayStation PlayStation
PlayStation yes okay so we're not gonna
be playing okay